- So, I'm Natalia.
I'll be teaching you today
about chemical reactions.
I'm a protein biochemist
and structural biologist
from the Rockefeller University
here in New York city.
And before we start learning a
bit about chemical reactions,
I just want to say that I
am so glad I could be here
to teach you all today,
and I'm gonna try to make this experience
a little bit interactive.
So I'll be asking some questions
and feel free to answer the
questions by unmuting your mic
or you can put it in the chat.
And so,
or you can raise your hand.
And so, I welcome questions,
so if you have a question
in the middle of the presentation,
you can just raise your hand
or you can unmute your mic,
ask question, or ask question in the chat.
And so I'll be telling you guys
a little bit about myself to begin with,
but just a little warm up question,
just to start exercising your minds.
I wanna ask you guys a question about
your favorite ice cream flavor.
So my favorite ice cream
flavor is mint choc chip.
So what is your favorite ice cream flavor?
If you have one, if you
even like ice cream.
- [Student 1] I personally like
sorbet more than ice cream,
but strawberry is my favorite.
- Yeah, I like strawberry
too, it's really refreshing.
Does anybody else wanna share
what they like?
- [Student 2] I like
mint chocolate cookie
and mint chocolate chunk.
- Oh, so you're like me.
(Natalia laughs)
- [Student 3] Well, somewhat,
I like chocolate, I guess,
there are a few other things I like.
- Yeah, I mean, yeah,
I mean, there's so many different flavors.
I'm pretty sure that my
favorite flavor changes,
you know, by the year.
So, not often, we have the same flavor.
- [Student 2] I also like sorbet
more than ice cream, but
if I do have to choose,
I choose mint chocolate
chip or cookie dough.
- Oh, cookie dough.
You know, I'm from Australia,
and we didn't have cookie dough ice cream
when I was growing up,
so when I came here,
I thought it was really amazing,
but, okay, so
I mentioned to you guys that I am
a structural biologist.
So I'm gonna share my
screen really quickly,
just to tell you guys a little
bit about what that means.
Actually, first of all, I
wanna ask you guys a question.
Ooh.
So does anybody know what a protein is?
- [Student 2] Yep.
(mouse clicking)
- Okay, it's my first poll.
So tell this to me in the poll.
- [Student 2] I wonder,
how did you do that?
- How did I do that?
How did I ask you a question?
- [Student 2] Yeah
- I have some controls
here that allow me to do it
because I'm the host of this presentation,
well, the co-host with Odaelys.
- [Student 3] I didn't
know you can do like
surveys on Zoom now.
- Yeah, you can.
I mean, I just learnt about
it last week, so, all right.
So I'm gonna end this poll.
- [Odaelys] So I could share the results.
- Oh, okay.
How do you see that?
- So, 86% said yes,
they know what a protein is,
- Okay, that's great.
- and 14% said, I've heard of it,
but I'm not sure what it is.
- That's okay.
So, proteins are found inside
or on the surface of cells.
And so they can be
bacterial cells or viruses
or on the surface of your skin
or inside your skin or brain cells
or any type of cell contains proteins.
And these proteins perform
important functions in the cell
which helps the cell to survive.
So I'm gonna share my screen
with you really quickly.
So can everyone see that?
- [Student 2] Yup.
- [Student 3] Interesting.
- [Natalia] So, oh, we've done that.
So, as I mentioned,
I am a protein biochemist
and structural biologist,
which means that my job
is to study proteins
and to understand what
those proteins look like.
And so to make that a little
bit more clear to you,
when I was in grad school, I
studied this bacterium here,
and this bacterium is called
Streptococcus pneumoniae.
And it causes the disease, pneumonia,
which is a disease of your lungs.
And so when you look a little closer
into the strep pneumoniae cells,
bacterial cells, you see
all this murky stuff.
And in that mixture of murky stuff
is where the bulk of the proteins are
that this disease causing
bacterium needs to survive.
And when you take an even closer look
at this murky stuff inside these cells,
this is what you see.
And, so all of these
different colored objects
are what is found inside a bacterial cell.
And your cells probably
look very similar to this
sort of, if not a bit more crowded.
- [Student 1] Are they
actually that colorful?
- [Natalia] Well, no.
this is just helping people to visualize
all the different proteins
and objects inside.
- [Student 4] Probably so that you can
easily tell them and visualize them
though not technically,
nothing is actually colored
since color is an illusion.
- [Natalia] Well, we'll be
talking about some proteins
that actually do have
a color a little later,
but here you see like, proteins,
and you see genetic
materials, such as your DNA
or this bacteria's DNA, bacterial
cell's DNA, and some RNA.
And so, this is what's inside a protein.
And so what protein biochemists wanna do
or what they do is they study
each of these individual proteins.
They study their function.
And so the reason is,
each of these proteins
are in such close contact
with other proteins,
so they actually work with other proteins.
So, just imagine each of
these circles is a protein
and each of these lines mean
there's proteins
interacting with each other
and so, protein biochemists
study the interactions
between proteins to understand
how bacteria survive
or how particular
functions inside bacteria
help them to cause disease.
- [Student 3] So, what are
proteins in like, in general?
- [Natalia] So proteins are essentially
objects inside the cell
that perform essential
functions in your cell
to help your cell survive.
So it's like the machinery of your cell
are performed by proteins.
And so, what you can do
so what I did as a structural biologist
is I got the structure of a protein.
So, this is the protein structure
that I solved in grad school.
And so this structure
allowed us to understand
how we can use this protein,
which is essential in
Streptococcus pneumoniae,
how we can use it to
potentially treat individuals
that have pneumonia by
targeting this protein
inside the bacteria.
- [Student 3] I didn't know
pneumonia was caused by proteins.
- [Natalia] Pneumonia
isn't caused by proteins,
it's caused by a bacterium,
and inside that bacterium are
thousands of proteins that are essential
for the bacteria to survive.
And so the idea is,
if you stop one of
those essential proteins
that the bacteria needs to survive,
you can kill the bacteria
and stop it from causing disease.
- [Student 4] So, question, I
don't know if you can hear me,
I have very bad audio but,
for the time being, so
you're saying, for example,
the life function in this bacteria
is made up out of small
chemicals called proteins
which consist of ATGP particles.
I know this because of prior knowledge,
but it's essentially like
life code, essentially?
I don't know life (mumbles)
- [Natalia] So, you're talking about DNA?
- [Student 4] No, not DNA, but like,
you said that proteins are the basic
building parts of a bacteria.
So, like, if you were to turn
one protein off in a bacteria,
would it have like,
would it turn off the special function?
Is that what you are saying?
- [Natalia] So, proteins perform
essential functions in
bacteria to help them survive.
And so, if, for example,
one protein made a particular nutrient
that a bacteria needed, right?
It was essential in manufacturing
a particular nutrient
inside a bacterial cell,
like an amino acid, for example.
And so if you stop that protein
from being able to perform its function,
then that bacteria can no longer
manufacture an essential
amino acid that it needs.
And so, without that amino acid,
the bacteria could no longer survive.
- [Student 4] Oh, I am
sorry, it was the ATGP stuff.
That (mumbles)
- [Natalia] Does that make sense?
- [Student 4] (mumbles)
- [Natalie] Okay.
- [Student 4] As for this
question that I was asking,
thank you for giving me the answer.
This was a premium lightning inquiry.
- [Natalia] Okay, would you be able to
repeat that question for me, sorry?
- [Student 4] No, you
answered it, I was saying--
- [Natalia] Oh, I answered it? Oh okay.
- [Student 4] I was saying, thank you.
- [Natalia] Oh, no worries, no problem.
Okay, so now, I'm gonna
move on a little bit.
So that's pretty much what it means
to be a protein biochemist
and a structural biologist.
- [Cameron] And, sorry, sorry.
- [Natalia] Yeah, go for it, Cameron.
- [Cameron] How many proteins
are in like, one cell usually?
- [Natalia] Oh, whoa,
that's like, who knows?
It's like, it could be hundreds,
a thousands upon thousands
of proteins inside your cell.
- [Cameron] Okay then.
- [Natalia] That's how
complicated human cells are
or any cell for that matter is.
They need a lot of things to survive.
Okay, so, now back to chemical reactions.
So, before I get into chemical reactions,
I'm gonna ask you guys
a series of questions.
So, my first question is
so, there are a lot of objects that
we can't see with just our eyes.
Can anybody name me an
object, just one person,
just an object that you
can see with your eye
- [Cameron] The computer.
- [Natalia] that's
taller than your teacher.
- [Student 3] Oh, well, I can see my bed
and it is taller than my teacher.
- [Teacher] I'm pretty
sure there's probably
a lot of things taller than me
- [Natalia] Okay, so how about an object
that is smaller than your fingernail?
- [Cameron] Well, I guess this.
- [Natalia] What's that Cameron?
- [Cameron] An eraser.
- [Natalia] An eraser.
How about something even
smaller than an eraser?
- [Cameron] A piece of dirt, I guess.
Like, or a grain of sand.
- [Natalia] That you
can see with your eye.
Yeah, a grain of sand, right?
An ant, a little bug.
So these things are really, really small.
And so the limit of what
you can see with your eyes
is about one millimeter.
And so if you wanted to see something,
so for example, one of the
largest things you can see,
like, one of the largest living organisms
on this earth is General Sherman,
which is a Sequoia tree in
the Sierra Nevada mountains.
You can see mice, you can see bugs,
but what if you wanted to see something
that was 1,000 times smaller than an ant?
You'd need a special microscope,
you'd need a light microscope.
And so can anybody tell
me what it could be
that is 1000 times smaller than an ant
that you might wanna see?
- [Sky] I think it,
I first thought like bug.
- [Natalia] Sky, what did you say, Sky?
(indistinct)
- [Student 4] I said--
- [Student 2] What about a sperm cell?
- [Natalia] A sperm cell?
Yeah, a cell, yeah.
- [Cameron] Maybe a super,
super, super young fetus.
- [Natalia] Yeah, like, yeah.
So we can see many different things that
you can see with a light microscope.
- [Sky] Those are actually I think
still somewhat visible.
You just can't see
through people's stomachs.
- [Natalia] Well, you can't
see them also with your eyes.
You need some assistance.
So you need a light microscope
'cause they're 1000 times
smaller than the smallest thing
you can see with your eye.
So, for example, you can't see
an individual red blood cell
with just your eye.
You need a microscope.
You can't see an individual bacterial cell
that you see over here.
You need a microscope.
You can't see an individual
skin cell to see all the parts
inside the skin cell without
the aid of a light microscope.
So these objects are about
1000 times smaller than a bug.
- [Student 1] Hello, I'm sorry (mumbles)
But what I did want to
say was that I think that,
what was I gonna say?
It was something,
that pond water?
I mean, algae is like
small enough to be seen
with a light microscope.
After all, we have seen algae in class.
- [Natalia] Yeah, you can't see algae
without light microscope.
So if you wanted to see something
that is 1000 times smaller
than each of these,
smaller than a bacterial cell,
smaller than a single cell, smaller than--
- [Student 4] I have a question.
- [Natalia] Sure.
- [Student 4] Is it
possible for something to be
so small, we cannot even
see it with a microscope?
- [Natalia] Yeah, so we're
just gonna, yeah, it is.
So for example, to see things like,
some of the smallest things,
you need special microscopes
and special techniques.
So for example, a virus particle,
you can't see it with a light microscope.
That is about 1000 times
smaller than your cells.
And you have proteins
which are 100 times
smaller than a virus cell
which you cannot see without
these special microscopes.
And then you have the even smaller cells,
your DNA that it's even
smaller than a protein
that you have to see with
these special microscopes.
And so what this is all
getting at is that often,
we can't see chemical
reactions from occurring.
They're performed by proteins,
they're performed with either proteins
and other chemicals in our atmosphere
that are smaller than DNA,
but there are some chemical
reactions that you can see.
And so, here are a couple
of chemical reactions
that you're able to see.
So for example, here, you
have a colorimetric reaction.
So two chemicals mixed together,
they form a color so you can visualize it.
And here on the right,
you have the phenomenon of bioluminescence
where you have these biological organs,
these organisms inside the seawater
that perform a chemical
reaction that produces light.
And so that's why you see
that they're blue here.
But today, what I'm
going to be showing you
are chemical reactions
that involve proteins.
And the protein that
we're going to be using
to teach you a bit more
about chemical reactions
is the protein green fluorescent protein.
So this protein actually fluoresces green
because of this part inside the protein
called a chromophore.
And so that's how the protein got its name
because it's green.
And so this protein is one of
the most widely used proteins
in science, because it
allows you to visualize
where things are in cells.
And so I have another question for you.
Let's see if I can, I tell
if I can, oh, here it is.
The poll question.
- [Student 2] Question,
green fluorescent--
- [Natalia] Where do you think--
- [Student 3] We're found on (mumbles)
- [Natalia] Where do
you think GFP is found?
- [Student 3] I don't, I'm sorry--
- [Natalia] So is it found
in the land or in the ocean?
- [Student 3] Well so, I'm
not going to say, well I'm--
- [Odaelys] Yeah, 50% who voted.
So I'll give you all a few more seconds.
So you have a 50% chance
of getting it right.
- [Natalia] Whoops, I might
have given the answer.
All right, so everybody--
- [Odaelys] Everyone
voted or wanted to vote?
I'll close it in five,
four, three, two, one.
- [Natalia] All right.
Okay, so what do people say?
I can't--
- [Odaelys] Awesome.
So a hundred percent of you all said
it was found in the ocean.
- [Natalia] Yeah, it's
found in these jellyfish.
The first species of
jellyfish called Aequorea.
I can't say that
properly, Latin, Victoria.
And as you can see, it's green because
in it cells it has this
protein that fluoresces green.
- [Student 3] Oh, okay, had
to do a little deduction
to get it.
The only thing that would
have probably have (mumbles)
of protein is plants.
And I don't know any plants
that can turn a bright green.
I'm pretty sure that
animals don't have this
other than seaborne
animals (mumbles) the ocean
I mean, the logical choice-
assuming what we know is true.
- [Student 5] Really
sorry, I completely forgot.
I thought it was next
period, not this period.
- [Natalia] That's okay, we know.
We're just gonna catch you up, okay?
Just reach out.
- [Student 6] Excuse me.
- [Natalie] Yeah, sure hi.
- [Student 6] Can you say
what specific topic we're on
because I've got question but
I'm not sure if it's on topic
or just on topic with
something you brought up but--
- [Natalia] Any question.
- [Student 6] I guess, (mumbles)
but particularly the
topic we're talking about?
- [Natalia] So we're talking about
chemical reactions involving proteins.
- [Student 6] Okay, yeah,
my question would be like,
since we were talking about
light in microscopic stuff
- [Natalia] Mm hmm.
- [Student 6] but did
you want me to ask it?
- [Natalia] So we were talking about
light microscopic stuff
just to introduce you
to things that you can't see.
- [Student 6] Yeah, exactly.
That's why this would be off topic.
- [Natalia] Yeah.
So, and this is the protein
that we're gonna be using
in the experiment that
I'm gonna show you later
that's gonna us to see
chemical reactions in action.
So, I'm just giving you a brief
introduction of this protein
before we start working with it.
So yeah, so this is one of the most
widely used proteins in science
and it was considered such
an important discovery
and it's so important and life-changing
to the fields of science that
the people that discovered this protein
were awarded the Nobel prize
which is one of the greatest prizes
any scientists can be awarded.
And so people recognized how
important this protein was
to scientists and it's incredibly
important till this day.
So before we move on
to chemical reactions,
I just wanted to make something clear.
So I mentioned before bioluminescence
and I mentioned before fluorescence.
And so I wanna ask you a quick question.
Are bioluminescence and
fluorescence the same thing?
- [Odaelys] So we have
about 60% who voted.
So those who would like to vote,
I'll give you a few more seconds.
So hopefully everyone can see the poll
where it's asking a yes or no question.
- [Natalia] So has everyone voted?
- [Student 1] Yeah I voted.
- [Natalia] Okay.
- [Odaelys] Awesome, so end the poll
and I'll share the results.
- [Natalia] Cool.
- [Odaelys] So we have about
80% that voted, no, and--
- [Jonah] It says 100% voted no
and 20% voted yes.
- [Student 3] It's not possible.
- [Odaelys] But that's not possible.
So I think Zoom has an error.
(Odaelys laughs)
But it's 80% it seems like
voted, no, and 20% voted, yes.
- [Jonah] Is it possible
to change your answer?
- [Odaelys] Okay.
- [Jonah] Or maybe some
people pressed both?
- [Odaelys] Oh, yeah.
- [Jonah] Went back and switched it?
- [Natalia] Yeah, maybe
it seem has a glitch
where you can log into the poll again.
- [Odaelys] Yeah, that's
probably what happened
but majority said, no.
- [Natalia] Okay, well the
majority are then correct
because bioluminescence,
as I mentioned before,
is actually a type of a phenomenon
called chemiluminescence.
And so that is where the
chemical reaction produces light
but it's called bioluminescence
because a biological entity
is creating the light.
So in this case, over
here with the blue light,
it's being caused by Dinoflagellates,
which are inside the water.
And as the water gets essentially agitated
by the person's hand or
by the waves crashing
on the shoreline,
you can start to see the
light being produced.
And on the right side here,
you see all of these little
bright lights happening here,
just twinkling inside this forest,
and that's been caused by this bug here,
and this is also another
case of bioluminescence.
So just quickly, does anybody
know what this bug might be?
- [Cameron] Firefly.
- [Natalia] Exactly, it's a Firefly
- [Cameron] And also is
bioluminescence basically
just one of the living things makes light?
- [Natalia] It's when a
chemical reaction result,
yeah, a living thing produces
a chemical reaction--
- [Student 1] Can I ask
does that mean
in what way, because,
can you be more specific
'cause if we're rubbing stick
together to make a fire,
technically, that would be
a living thing you know, making the light.
- [Cameron] When the proteins make light.
- [Student 3] It's right,
'cause it's the use of tools
making the fire.
Also it's two sticks that you
are using that made the fire
not necessarily your own chemical fluid.
- [Cameron] Technically it's
the sticks making the reaction.
- [Natalia] Yes, so there's
two ways to make light, Jonah?
So there's a couple of
different ways to make light.
And so we're gonna go
through that, but like,
yeah, you can make light, you
know, physically, you know?
And then you can make light
how these animals do it
internally using chemicals
inside their body
and proteins that help
them create the light.
So these are chemical reactions
that are inside the animal
that produces light.
And so, yeah.
- [Jonah] There's music so
then in, okay, thank you.
- [Natalia] So biolumi...
This might make it a
little clearer for you.
So bioluminescence is a
type of chemical reaction
that's referred to as a
synthesis chemical reaction.
And so what that means is
that you have one object
plus another object, which creates this,
synthesizes this new object, which is AB.
- [Jonah] Excuse me.
- [Natalia] Sure.
- [Jonah] That would mean
A plus B equals A times B.
- [Natalia] This isn't a
standard mathematical question.
This is a chemical reaction.
So it's a little bit different.
- [Jonah] Yeah, but
- [Student 4] Well,
basically it means (mumbles)
- [Student 3] It could be equal to two.
Two plus two is four, and
two times two is four.
- [Natalia] Okay, so let's go through
this chemical reaction here
and try to wipe away
mathematics from your mind
for a second.
So what A is, for example,
is a compound called luciferin.
So it's a chemical compound.
And then in the presence of
oxygen in the atmosphere,
this protein called luciferase
combines the two together,
helps combine the two together
to produce this new compound
called oxyluciferin,
and that oxyluciferin releases light.
And so this is essentially
what's happening
when the dinoflagellates
and the fireflies are producing light.
It's this luciferin reacting with oxygen
which is helped by this
protein called luciferase
which produces oxyluciferin
which then releases the light.
- [Jonah] So does that
mean light is considered--
- [Student 4] Have I missed something?
- [Jonah] Wait, can I say something?
- Does that mean light is considered
physical matter rather than energy?
- [Natalia] Well, light
has energy, but it's--
- [Jonah] Yeah, but is light considered
physical matter or energy?
- [Natalia] It's a physical
property that has energy.
- [Teacher] Let me give you a little--
- [Jonah] It's like plasma,
as in the combination.
- [Student 3] It's sort
of like, imagine this.
So, luciferin plus 02
equals a bit of energy which creates light
and also oxyluciferin,
So the bit of energy turned into light
because that's the way it was exhorted
'cause you not just
keep the energy inside,
you have to let it go
because energy is made
from chemical reactions.
- [Cameron] I think it's
basically when, like,
there's one thing and another thing
and then they combine
into a chemical reaction
and create something else.
- [Natalia] So, yeah, so this--
- [Jonah] Wait, let me ask this.
Is light then,
does that mean it's made of like matter?
- [Student 3] No.
- [Cameron] It's made up of
like resin particles and stuff.
- [Natalia] So it's
(Natalie laughs)
Yeah, so light is high energy.
Sunlight is something
that is visible because
it's made up of component of
many different types of light, right?
- [Jonah] So I'm asking,
here is the light
made partly of matter?
- [Cameron] And light
is type of radiation.
Like, there's lots of different types
like infrared and
microwave that we can't see
but are still there.
- [Natalia] Yeah.
- [Jonah] That's not what I'm asking.
- [Teacher] Jonah,
light is an energy form.
It's a form of energy.
So even if light is coming
from the interaction of matter,
light itself is energy.
It's something that gets
measured in photons, it's energy.
- [Jonah] Okay, so there's no matter?
So what happens to the matter 'cause--
- [Natalia] It interacts with matter.
- [Teacher] Yes, it's
interacting with the matter
or it's coming from an
interaction of matter,
but it's itself being given off as energy.
- [Cameron] It's basically
just energy coming
from the sun in a way.
- [Student 4] Well, it's
coming from the sun--
- [Jonah] Then it has to
be created or destroyed.
- [Cameron] Probably blue
or white or whatever.
- [Teacher] Yeah.
- [Jonah] so it can created nor destroyed.
So how does the chemical
reaction, a combination of two?
- [Natalia] It's got to do
with the compound luciferin.
It's a special type of compound
which has the ability to emit photons.
- [Teacher] Yeah.
- [Natalia] And so that's
how it produces the light.
- [Jonah] So wait, is light like
plasma then?
- [Natalia] I don't really know--
- [Teacher] Plasma is a type of matter.
- [Natalia] Plasma is a type--
- [Jonah] It's basically matter
with electric charge.
- [Natalia] It's not.
- [Jonah] Okay.
- [Cameron] No, I'm not.
- [Natalia] They're different
- [Cameron] Yeah, and--
- [Natalia] So
(phone ringing)
- [Jonah] Give me a second.
- [Natalia] Okay, so this is fluorescence.
So this is two types of fluorescence.
So fluorescence is a physical property
not caused by a chemical reaction.
And so what's happening here is that
you have this chromophore in the protein
which absorbs light at
a particular wavelength
and then it emits light.
And so if your chromophore
is a green chromophore,
it'll emit green light,
if it's a red chromophore,
it'll emit red light.
So fluorescence is a physical property
not caused by a chemical reaction.
- [Cameron] Wait, so
it's basically just like
something that happens
that's not caused by a chemical reaction?
- [Natalia] It's not
caused by chemicals, yeah.
So, it is probably--
- [Student 4] So like this.
Okay, so like, think of it like a stack.
It is fluorescent?
Glow stick, yes.
Chair, no.
Like that?
- [Natalia] Sorry, I couldn't quite
- [Cameron] What is it
like in simple terms?
- [Student 4] Is it like a stat?
Like,
- [Natalie] What's a stat?
- [Student 4] Glow stick is fluorescent
but a chair is not.
- [Natalia] Yeah.
- [Student 4] Oh, I
thought I was incorrect.
- [Natalia] So this chromophore
has the ability to emit
lights of a particular color
depending on which light it absorbs.
- [Cameron] Wait, is it
when a thing emits light
without a chemical reaction?
- [Natalia] Yeah, it's when...
So fluorescence is not
caused by a chemical reaction
that has the ability to emit light.
- [Cameron] And does it
have to be living thing?
- [Natalia] It has to
be a functional thing.
I mean, this is a protein that
has the ability to do that.
It will do that when it's
not even inside a cell.
So it doesn't have to be a living thing.
It just has to be a functional thing.
So the protein will be able to fluoresce.
It's like your glow stick
will be able to fluoresce or whatever
without being inside a cell, yeah.
- [Cameron] Which so it's basically like
the opposite of bioluminescence?
- [Natalia] Yeah, because it
needs other things around it
to be able to perform its function.
Like, it can't just put it on its own.
So like this protein can
create this color on its own.
It can fluoresce on its own,
it was bioluminescence it requires
sort of like,
it'll require the
luciferase enzyme to help
bring together the luciferin
and the oxygen to produce, yeah,
the oxyluciferin in the light,
whereas here, it just needs light.
And so when it absorbs light,
it emits light of a particular wavelength.
So yeah, it emits green light
which is the chromophore
absorbs blue light.
(mouse clicking)
- [Student 3] Natalia, do
you know how thankful I am
for having you here today?
You have put in a lot of
energy into doing this,
and I'd like to thank
you. (Natalia laughs)
- [Natalia] Oh, thank you.
- [Student 3] Invisible (mumbles)
- [Natalia] Oh no, we're
gonna start getting into
the visible part.
Okay, so today, so let's see
how we're doing with time.
I think we're good.
So I'm gonna do two examples
of chemical reactions
that involve proteins.
And so the first chemical
reaction is going to be
a protein test.
So the chemical reaction will
occur and it'll be a visible,
it will be a color change.
So you'll be able to see
the chemical reaction
if protein is present in the solution.
And then the second
chemical reaction will be
the effects that different
chemical environments have
on fluorescent proteins.
Okay, so let's see if
we can get this started.
- [Odaelys] Francis,
I mean, Natalia, yeah.
I was just gonna say,
stop sharing your screen.
- It's okay, so, okay.
- So, how do I make myself enlarged?
'cause at the moment
you're the largest
thing. I can see Odaelys.
Okay, I don't know if, oh, okay.
- [Odaelys] Oh, I was on mute.
Sorry, are you gonna use the camera
that you're looking in right now?
- Yeah, I'm just gonna use my--
- [Odaelys] So, I just
spotlighted the video,
so now everyone sees you.
- Oh, okay, cool, okay.
Try to focus on my workbench here.
- [Odaelys] So now she's gonna show you
what the reactions look like.
So she's at her bench
taking her supplies out.
So she has some tools
that's gonna allow her
to add and remove liquid.
- [Cameron] This is cool.
- [Student 3] This is very cool.
(indistinct)
- Everybody can sort of see this.
- [Odaelys] Mm hmm.
- So I have
to start with, I have my proteins.
So I have two proteins here.
See if you can see these guys.
Can you see them?
- [Student 3] One is
like the red fluorescent
and the other is, what is it?
Green fluorescent the others--
- [Cameron] If proteins are in cells,
and how did you get them out of the cells?
- Oh, okay, so this is the
green fluorescent protein.
This is the red fluorescent protein.
And so the way that I got
them out of cells is I first,
I cloned the gene into a bacterial cell.
I don't know if you can see this.
- [Cameron] Kind of.
- And so on this plate
is individual bacterial cells
that I cloned the gene into.
And so when I cloned the gene
that produces green fluorescent
protein into these cells,
the cells started to produce
that green fluorescent protein.
And then I was able to extract
the protein from these cells.
- [Cameron] That's cool.
- And that's what you see here.
That's the extracted
green fluorescent protein
from those bacterial cells.
And so pretty much,
you can clone any gene,
pretty much any gene into specific cells,
and those cells can start
making those proteins,
and then you can purify those
proteins from those cells.
And so that's our green
fluorescent protein
- [Student 1] You know, it's
also possible to actually
clone animals like--
- Like a full animal?
- [Student 1] Ah huh?
- I mean, yeah, there was Dolly the sheep.
There was a sheep that was
cloned from another sheep.
- [Jonah] You can pay
like I think, $20,000
to clone your dog.
- [Odaelys] Mm hmm.
- Really?
I didn't even know that.
- [Jonah] Crazy, right?
- [Cameron] What do you mean clone them?
- [Jonah] Get a puppy
with the exact same genes.
- [Cameron] What would
that actually do though?
- [Jonah] What?
- [Student 3] And it undertakes
a lot of dangerous testing.
I don't know if it's a good idea.
- [Teacher] Ton of waste of money.
[Student 4] So it just comes
out with an actual alive dog?
- [Jonah] Yup.
- [Student 1] Yeah.
- [Cameron] That's creepy.
- [Sky] It's not like
a machine or anything.
It's, do you know how IVF works?
It's you can take a dish,
a Petri dish with like
an embryo or whatever,
inject sperm into that Petri dish,
and it can grow an embryo.
(mumbles)
- Okay guys.
- [Teacher] Focus guys.
- Focus.
So we've got these three tubes
here and you can see that,
tubes one, two, and three.
And so we're gonna use this protein assay.
This dye here, and this dye
when it comes in contact with
protein, it'll change color.
And so that's the chemical reaction.
And so we're gonna see
which of these tubes has protein in them.
And you can already tell that
some of them have protein in them
but we'll see whether the dye picks up
those tubes that contain the protein.
Okay, so I'll just get some tubes out.
Oop.
Okay, so we'll do a control
'cause you always have
to perform a control.
And then we've got
tune one, two, and three.
So, a lot of the times when
you're performing experiments,
you want to know how
much protein is inside,
oh, how much protein you have
because you wanna be able to
reproduce that experiment.
It's like a recipe.
So if you don't know how much
sugar to add in your recipe,
you won't be able to reproduce
that recipe very well.
Okay, so let's do one and,
right.
- [Student 3] I think that like
cloning procedure is pretty,
I think that this way
is sort of efficient.
This way of doing tests is
really efficient, eyes focus.
It's fluorescent of
course, it's pretty good.
- And so I'm gonna do a control
tube that just has water.
- [Student 3] That's pretty smart
'cause I only know the difference between,
but what would happen is
we'd never put this protein
in at all?
What's the difference?
- Exactly, so whenever
you perform an experiment,
you always have to have correct
controls because someone is,
they ask you,
how do you know what
you're seeing is real?
Okay, so now, I'm gonna add my dye
and we'll see what happens, right?
So here's my dye, it's brown.
So add it to the control tube.
Okay.
- [Jonah] Oh my God.
Oh my God.
What?
- Is everything all right over there?
- [Jonah] Sorry, I just saw
experiments I really want to do.
- Oh yeah?
- [Jonah] Yeah, I think,
you see the thing called an ecosphere
which is basically
like a ecosystem inside a little like
aquatic ecosystem, self-sustaining
ecosystem inside like a,
- [Student 3] Oh my
gosh. The water (mumbles)
- [Jonah] Aquatic one, or you
have put it some light and
directing it on the window cell?
- [Teacher] All right, Jonah,
let's take a look at this experiment.
- [Jonah] Oh yeah.
- [Teacher] The control is in her hand.
- This control is this one here, sorry.
So we'll just, it's
hard to sort of like...
So the control is this one.
It's in my hand over here,
and then lets see if I can
- [Jonah] Wait- the food
coloring- going to the control?
- So this is the control
and then you have tubes
one, two, and three.
- [Cameron] So why are
they different colors?
- [Student 3] Cameron, think about this.
The water just diluted the original thing.
And so, because the
original thing was tainted
a certain color,
the other ones after
the chemical reactions
or the control, didn't because the--
- [Cameron] What's the
original color of the dye?
- This is the original color of the dye.
So the water I added, I added
400 times more dye than water.
So the water would not
have been able to dilute
the control reaction.
So this is pretty much just the color
of the dye with no protein.
However, when you start adding protein,
you start to see a color change to the dye
so it is no longer brown, but
starts to become blue, right?
- [Odaelys] And I launched a poll.
- [Cameron] So the blue ones
are fluorescent proteins?
- So, this has nothing
to do with fluorescent.
This is a chemical
reaction that's happening
between the dye and the protein.
- [Student 3] The protein.
So the one and two have protein in it.
Does three have a protein?
- So, how about we launch a
poll question really quickly
to see which tubes do you
think contain protein in them?
- [Student 3] Tubes or two.
- [Teacher] One tube, so you'll pick one.
- [Odaelys] Which one
contains the most protein?
- So do you guys, yeah.
- [Student 3] Either way, this
is a multiple choice question
or it looks like it's a multiple choice.
- [Teacher] Yes, so you
only get to pick one.
- [Natalia] You have to pick one.
- [Student 3] Oh no, I picked twice.
- [Natalia] You were able
to do that? Yay, Zoom poll.
- [Cameron] I chose one and two.
- [Odaelys] You can only
choose one, choose one.
(Odaelys laughs)
- [Jonah] Why do I have
to choose number one?
Why can't choose number three?
- [Odaelys] 'Cause there's only one.
- [Student 1] Only get one choice.
- You get to choose one choice
on the multiple choices.
Is everyone in?
- [Odaelys] I'll give a few more seconds.
Anyone else?
- [Cameron] Oh, now I understand, okay.
- [Student 3] I made a
mistake? Oh gosh, I can't see--
- [Student 3] All of them have water?
- [Odaelys] So, her
control tube had water.
So the one by itself.
And then one, two, and three
had a certain amount of protein
in each of them.
So she did a chemical
reaction to see which tube
has the most protein.
The question is, which tube
do you think has the most protein?
- So there was a question,
Which tube has protein
and then which tube has the most protein?
So did you guys get both questions?
- [Odaelys] Oh no, I just did
which tube has the most protein?
- Oh, sorry.
One of the questions was
which of these tubes do
you think contains protein
if this is the control here?
- [Odaelys] I can ask
that question quickly.
- Yeah, so we'll ask that question.
So which of the tubes contains protein?
That's could be a
multiple choice question.
- [Cameron] Well, a lot of
them have protein in it.
- Yeah, so just we'll see
the results of the poll.
- [Student 3] Oh no, I was wrong.
- [Student 1] I got it wrong.
I didn't mean to get it wrong though.
- Lets see, this is control here.
- [Student 3] I miss clicked on it.
- Okay, so has everyone answered?
- [Cameron] I don't
understand what happened.
Like, why are they colored differently?
- Okay, so we'll answer
the first question first.
Which tube do you think contain protein?
- [Odaelys] So I'm sharing the results.
So the majority said two, one, and two,
and the close second was all tubes.
- Right, so yeah.
All tubes contained protein.
As you can see, there
is a slight difference
between tube three and the control.
And so the second question was
which tube do you think
contains the most protein?
- [Cameron] Wait, wait, wait, wait.
So what happened?
- Yeah, so when we answer
which tube contains the most protein,
- [Student 5] It makes it look different.
There are different amounts
of protein between each thing.
- Yeah.
- [Odaelys] Now the next
question is which tube
out of one, two, and three
that Natalia has in her hand,
do you think has the most protein?
- [Cameron] But I thought
three of them were protein
and one of them was water?
- [Odaelys] Yeah, so one,
two, and three has protein.
- This one is the control
reaction that has water.
And so at the start,
we didn't know which of
these tubes have protein.
And so we're basing this
all on the chemical reaction
that's taking place that you
can see before your eyes,
which is the color changing
from brown to blue.
- [Cameron] Why is three gray?
- Has everybody answered that question?
The second question about which
tube has the most protein?
- [Odaelys] Yeah, we
have 50% of people voted.
Anyone else wants to vote?
Can we have one more vote
in and I'll close the poll.
So there's a tie with two and
three having the most protein,
with two, one, coming in a close second.
- So two and three have the most protein?
Is that what was--
- [Odaelys] Yeah, that's what was chosen.
- Okay, so if this control
tube here just contains water
and has no protein,
this has the least
amount of protein in it.
- [Student 3] I know.
- And then the one where
the chemical, the most,
the greatest chemical reaction,
the greatest degree of
chemical reaction has occurred
is the one where it is the most
visibly different to the control tube.
So number one is the
most visibly different
to the control tube.
- [Student 3] Oh sorry my
brightness is very low.
So, one and two looked
like the same thing to me.
- Oh, that's okay, that's all right.
- [Cameron] Why is three gray, though?
- Because there's just a
small color change happening.
So it's the result of there
being some blue formation,
which makes a little
bit gray and less brown.
- [Cameron] Oh, so there's
not that much protein
in number three?
- Yeah, there's not that
much protein in number three,
there's more protein in number two
and there's the most
protein in number one.
I'm sorry, Samuel that
you can't really see
'cause of like, the resolution
- [Cameron] But it was
brown dye originally?
- Yeah, it was this color originally.
And then in the presence of protein,
more and more amounts of
protein in the solution,
more of that chemical reaction can occur
and produce this blue color.
- [Student 1] It's like
the more protein in it,
the more blue it'll be.
- Exactly, and so, I'm just gonna
go back to the presentation real quick,
so let me take my gloves off.
So that chemical reaction
is a synthesis reaction that's happening.
So you have the protein,
and you put the protein
in a solution with a particular dye
that only binds to protein.
And that dye, when it binds to protein,
it becomes this protein dye
combination which releases a blue color.
And that's just specific to the dye.
The dye, when it binds to
protein, it releases a particular,
it changes state and it
produces a blue color.
And so that's a synthesis
chemical reaction
that's occurring.
And so, yeah, so the
more protein you have,
the more dye can react
and then produce that
blue color that you saw.
That's why you have more blue
in the presence of a
greater amount of protein.
So we've already answered these questions.
- [Cameron] But why does dye
cause a chemical reaction?
- It's just the property of the dye.
So this dye reacts specifically, Oh, wait.
Okay, I can't seem to find my controls.
Sorry.
Seems like, okay.
So I don't know if you, did you guys,
did I share my screen?
- [Odaelys] Ah, no.
- [Natalia] Oh, sorry.
Let me just, okay.
- There you go.
- Okay.
Sorry.
- [Student 3] Luminescent proteins?
Oh no, nevermind.
- [Natalia] So yeah, so this is what's
essentially happening, is the dye
specifically interacts with
things only found on proteins.
So there are particular amino
acids that are only found,
amino acid combinations that
are only found on proteins
that the dye will then bind to.
And then when the dye binds to
the particular amino acid regions
that are found on proteins,
it produces that blue color.
And so it's just the particular
properties of this dye.
And this dye is called coomassie blue.
It's called coomassie blue
because in the presence
of protein, it goes blue.
And so, yeah, so this is a protein dye.
And so this is just one example of how
proteins are involved
in chemical reactions.
And so actually, I'll go
back to the presentation.
A second example of a chemical reaction.
We've done that, oopsies.
Okay, it's fluorescent proteins
in different environments.
And so I'm gonna show you what happens
when you put fluorescent proteins
in different chemical environments.
So what I'm gonna show you now
is what's gonna happen
to, where's my protein?
Okay.
Oh, so how, Odaelys,
how do I pin myself to the screen?
- [Odaelys] Well, if you
go to the three dots,
- [Natalia] Ah huh.
- [Odaelys] I can do it actually
and then spotlight for everyone.
I just did it.
- Okay.
So I'm gonna be working
with this protein here.
That's the green fluorescent protein.
And so I'm just gonna,
I have a control tube with
the green fluorescent protein
so we can compare to, so this is.
Ooh, let me see.
It's really hard to focus the
camera, same protein, right?
- [Student 3] Oh, two of the same protein.
- Yeah, and so now, I'm gonna add
this clean solution
which is an acid.
- [Student 3] I think
acids dissolve protein?
That like you messed up the
entire experiment or something?
- Well, let's see what happens.
- [Student 3] All right lets...
- I got my amino acid.
- [Student 3] Maybe I won't be correct.
I'll never know until we figure out.
- And then I've got my protein.
And so let's start adding
slowly to the side.
Mix it a bit.
- [Student 3] Oh, I love this.
I'm really do.
- Still pretty much the same.
Maybe a little bit of a
color change, but let's see.
Let's keep adding a little bit more acid.
- [Student 3] To which one?
- To our green fluorescent
protein, this tube here.
Okay.
Just a little bit more acid.
Okay, so here.
Okay.
So these are our two proteins.
So this is the one that
I'm adding acid to.
Can anybody see anything?
- [Cameron] The two looks
a little bit brighter.
- This one's little bit brighter.
I'll add a little bit more
acid and see what happens.
Okay.
Here we go.
This could throw it over the edge.
Okay guys.
What happened?
- [Jonah] It's just gone.
- [Cameron] What happened to it?
- It lost its ability to fluoresce
in an acidic environment.
So, do you think we can
restore this back to this?
- [Cameron] Well, if we took it out as,
or if we added in more
like, water, I guess.
- Well what, or just dilute it?
- [Student 1] How about we add protein?
- Well, adding more protein
might do something too but
let's see how about we add something
that is the opposite of an acid.
Let's add a base.
So this is my base.
It's another clear solution.
So this is just really concentrated base.
- [Student 3] I don't
know what it would do.
- Okay, so let's just
add a little bit of base
and see what happens.
Then we have
the fluorescence restored to
the green fluorescent protein.
- [Student 3] Oh, so the
protein adapted really quickly.
- Yeah, 'cause it's a chemical reaction.
And so
- [Student 3] I thought it was just like,
huh, maybe I was wrong.
- So green fluorescent protein,
the way that it fluoresces,
is not due to a chemical reaction,
but when you change its
environment with chemicals,
the chemicals then react with the protein
to form their own
chemical reactions, right?
And so that's why when you add the acid,
something happens, a
chemical reaction takes place
with the green fluorescent protein
which makes it stop fluorescing,
and then when you add the base,
this solution here, it changed
the chemical environment
that the green fluorescent protein within,
and then it restored back the
fluorescence of the protein.
So I'm just gonna sh...
So let's see what's going on there.
So let's share my screen.
Okay.
So what's happening.
So when we added acid to the tube,
we saw that as we added more acid,
the protein stopped fluorescing.
And then we added base to the tube
but we saw that the
fluorescence was restored.
And so what we're seeing
here is an example
of a chemical reaction called
a replacement chemical reaction.
And so what a replacement
chemical reaction is,
is you have A plus BC, for example,
and then the C no longer is with the B
but joins together with
the A and produces B.
And so what happened is
we have our green fluorescent protein.
We added an acid, hydrochloric acid,
and so what happened is
the hydrochloric acid,
the H part of the hydrochloric acid
attached itself to the GFP
which stopped the chromophore
from performing its function,
of fluorescing, of emitting light.
And so that's what we saw here.
We saw a replacement reaction.
And so then what happened
with the base is the opposite.
So the base essentially
displaced the hydrochloric
acid from the protein
restoring the ability of the
chromophore to fluorescent.
So that's what's happening here.
So what happens is in
the presence of the acid,
the H, the hydrogen from
the hydrochloric acid
attaches to the nitrogen group of this
aromatic ring here on the chromophore.
And then when we added
base, it neutralized it.
So it removed the hydrogen
from this nitrogen,
returned the chromophore
back to its neutral state,
allowing the protein to fluoresce again.
And so that is the end
of chemical reactions today.